ok ok
ce qui est très violent c'est que au
Blackface dont on discute parfois
s'ajoute là les cris de singe
c'est-à-dire que là on est carrément
dans le racisme ordinaire revendiqué
donc ça fait très mal c'est assez rare
parce que il y avait eu à
Villeneuve-d'Ascq en 2017 ça dans un
établissement scolaire mais il y avait
pas les cris de singe là c'est ultra
violent quoi alors ça y est au lycée
Diderot ce sont pas le visage en anglais
cet acte est évidemment négrophobe et
nous comptons sur les frères de
Marseille pour faire en sorte que ses
élèves soient sévèrement sanctionnés
voilà donc la vidéo a été partagée sur
Twitter avec cette légende oui
évidemment qu'il faut les exclure tout
est choquant le black
et le plus choquant parce qu'il me
choque c'est le fait de filmer cette
vidéo et de la diffuser et je trouve ça
témoigne d'un fléau aujourd'hui qu'en
fait les jeunes pour exister sur les
réseaux sociaux sont prêts à n'importe
quoi à quoi mettre tes pires horreurs et
à blesser les gens il y en a qui les
blessé physiquement on a vu les
agressions tout ça pour faire des des
likes du buzz et maintenant c'est blessé
moralement et être ouvertement raciste
donc évidemment qu'il faut les exclure
c'est débile de faire ça et ça doit être
sévèrement sur le sonné est-ce qu'il y
en a qui pensent qu'il faut pas les
exclure euh non personne ici tout le
monde pense que à part Gégé en fait le
problème c'est que évidemment c'est
au-delà de révoltant au-delà de choquant
mais en fait c'est une sorte de racisme
tellement crasse et tellement décomplexé
en fait je me dis mais c'est pas
possible en fait mais qui qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont dans la tête comment ils ont
été éduqués en fait c'est juste
incroyable mais le problème c'est que si
on les si on les août si on dit qu'ils
sont en fait le problème c'est que j'ai
peur que après malheureusement même
s'ils sont racistes et c'est ignoble
j'ai peur qu'on s'en prenne à eux qu'on
les agresse et que ce soit pire moi je
pense qu'il vaut mieux faire il vaut
mieux les sanctionner mais faire de la
pédagogie en même temps en parler
expliquer pourquoi ces catastrophique
parce qu'ils sont quand même jeunes et
on peut pas non plus complètement les
les exclure de la société voilà ils ont
un âge de la pédagogie je pense que le
problème c'est qu'on est même pas le
produit
c'est juste mais en fait bien sûr qu'il
y a pas de projet mais donc ils ont quoi
ils ont 15 ans on va dire
l'autre jour le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les enfants n'ont plus
peur de leurs parents qui n'ont plus
peur d'émettre des décolles qui n'ont
plus peur de la police qui peur de la
justice plus personne n'a peur de rien
bah effectivement encore une fois je
suis désolé il faut créer de la crainte
il faut créer de la peur
on les met quoi on les met en prison on
les met dans un centre éducatif fermé il
faut croire je ne suis pas jeune il faut
qu'il craignent une punition qui
comprennent la danger l'acte qu'ils ont
fait que j'ai jamais mais il faut bien
marqué il faut marquer absolument quand
même leur Kelly après Gilbert non c'est
ça on n'a pas dit à jamais moi je pense
qu'il faut absolument marquer le coup
parce que là on dit des lycéens mais
enfin moi je considère que c'est des ce
sont des adultes je considère plus ça
comme des enfants moi des lycéens donc
je trouve ça hyper grave de faire ça à
ce stage là évidemment c'est un primaire
mais là pour moi ce sont des adultes
donc en fait il faut marquer le coup et
bien sûr les punir et bien sûr les
exclure quitte à les faire revenir mais
on peut pas laisser ça impuni pour tous
les gens que ça a blessé même oui mais
sauf que si on sait qu'ils sont et si
jamais ils sont outés si jamais il y a
des gens pour se vendre
la peur que elle a peur que de coupable
surtout pas les plaindre en fait mais
juste il faut les sanctionner et en même
temps essayer d'éduquer tout le monde en
fait c'est ça qui est compliqué là où je
comprends Géraldine c'est qu'avec Kelly
on regardait il y a déjà sur les réseaux
des appels inadmissibles à des répliques
qui sont identifiés du côté de Marseille
sans regarder ça tout à l'heure donc ça
bien sûr Géraldine il ne faut pas
néanmoins ce geste bien sûr néanmoins ce
geste conscient là raciste il mérite une
exclusion alors après on peut débattre
temporaire ou définitive mais il faut
marquer le coup on peut pas tolérer ça
dans nos établissements scolaires
mais moi déjà j'ai de la peine parce que
ça en 2022 par des adultes presque des
adultes moi je rejoins Kelly sont grands
c'est son grand c'est mecs là faire ça à
Marseille en 2022 et les exclus en moi
mais les exclure de quoi du lycée après
on les met dans un autre lycée ils
refont la même chose dans un autre lycée
mais c'est sanction mais c'est pour ces
mecs là qui font ça c'est même pas une
sanction de l'élection du lycée ils ont
pas rien à [ __ ] ben ils en ont rien à
[ __ ] quoi ils en ont rien à [ __ ] il
faut il faut peut-être faire autre chose
plus sévère
de la société peuvent être modifiées
là-dessus je vous rejoins franchement
pas d'une tarte dans la gueule
généralement ça va plus loin que ça va
de son responsable mais qu'est-ce que tu
fais quand on doit faire 15 ans
2 minutes on tape dans la parole
qui sont des appareils ils ont pas les
moyens
que ce soit physique ou même au niveau
des de tout en fait la vie des fois elle
est compliquée et on a pas le choix donc
finir les parents systématiquement je
suis pas d'accord
non non je veux dire à Mathieu parfois
moi mes parents ils m'ont aimé m'ont
fait tout ce que j'avais je manquais de
RAM mais je faisais les plus grosses
conneries de la terre et même à 14 ans
et même à 15 ans j'allais plus à l'école
à 15 ans et j'ai fait ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'on aurait mis mes
parents parce que j'étais un petit con
on aurait on aurait sanctionné les
parents alors que mon père qu'est-ce
qu'il faisait de mal se lever à 4h30
pour aller conduire un camion et rentrer
rincer le soir et ma mère pareil elle
faisait son boulot elle partait le matin
à 6h dans le métro et on les aurait puni
eux parce que j'étais un petit
condomètre
mais c'est problème là bah ça
n'intéresse pas les victimes quoi encore
une fois
c'est compliqué tout ça c'est j'ai pas
fait de victime ou tu mets le curseur ou
tu mets le curseur
quel que soit les conditions de Big Shaq
peut-être à 10 ans je t'accompagne à 10
ans tiens ton enfant à 12 ans tiens ton
enfant mais une fois que tu as 14 15
c'est plus notre génération à nous
Mathieu nous on est rincé on a 45 50 ans
les mecs à 14-15 ans tu as vu des mondes
de 14 ans comment ils vont super vite
ils vont plus vite que nous c'est plus
c'est fini ça 15 ans je te signale tu
dois rentrer à 22h donc qu'est-ce qu'on
fait je vous écoute ils ont 14 15 ans on
peut pas les enfermer ils ont 14 15 ans
on peut pas on peut pas on peut pas
réprimer
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors je suis un
peu d'accord
pas changer toutes les lois là tu peux
les changer comme des adultes
non mais moi j'aurais tendance à dire
comme comme Mathieu parce que je me
demande quand même c'est si pour en
arriver là
les deux comparaissent des bêtises quand
tu étais petit
je pense qu'ils ont entendu des choses
chez eux peut-être qui les a motivés
pour faire ça et il faut pas oublier
aussi que si on ne les sanctionne pas
maintenant on les retrouvera dans les
stades parce qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de footballeurs qui
régulièrement
c'est de la merde qui a eu l'idée ici de
faire ça dans une cour de récréation il
y a un moment où ça vient quand même de
quelque part
ça nous est pas arrivé parce que parce
que nos parents n'ont pas indiqué sur
notre éducation encore une fois déjà si
tu as dit que les enfants je suis
d'accord donc
juste qu'il faudrait que les enfants
maintenant et les ados aient peur de
leurs parents déjà il faut qu'il a peur
qu'il change de camp c'est vrai que s'il
y avait une vraie sanction moi j'avais
peur de moi ils ont peur de toi
malheureusement pas ceux qui connaissent
non mais non megapart malheureusement
ils ont pas forcément des enfants n'ont
pas peur de toi et moi j'ai moi mon père
quand j'avais un bulletin de notes et
qui avait une mauvaise note il faut dire
que je je me chie dans mon froc pas des
enfants ils ont pas vendeur parce que
j'étais parce que j'étais élevé un peu
la génération un peu partout et moi un
peu à la dure et bon je vais être plus
cool et c'est une bêtise et aujourd'hui
effectivement si les enfants les ados et
même avec les jeunes adultes avaient
peur qu'il y avait une skins sanction
une vraie sanction croyez-moi que ce
serait pas la même chose et aujourd'hui
moi je regrette c'est pas de cogner
évidemment les enfants mais s'il y avait
un respect de l'autorité et qu'ils
avaient peur de quelque chose de quelque
chose que ce soit les parents ou
d'autres choses d'ailleurs mais ils
n'ont plus peur de rien ni des flics ni
les surveillants ni des profs ni de rien
il y a plus de respect et tant qu'il y
aura pas de respect il y aura des
problèmes et on attend après on va
pleurer parce qu'effectivement je te
rejoins c'est là on en rigole mais après
c'est quoi c'est une barre de fer il se
cogne dans la rue ils sont à sec sur une
personne et il y a des drames il faut
réinstaurer le respect au sens général
moi je pense à ça comment tu fais
[Applaudissements]
moi je respectais mon père parce que
j'en avais peur effectivement une ou
deux fois et ben il m'a il m'a dit
une fois j'ai une mauvaise note quand il
prend le bulletin il dit c'est quoi ça
bah c'est une note mais c'est quelle
note bah c'est une note c'est combien
il savait pas dire
et d'ailleurs Julien m'a fait une
remarque chérie Julien m'a fait normal
qui est mon aîné où j'étais un peu plus
dur avec lui effectivement Julien quand
il apprenait pas une leçon effectivement
il veut vivre d'un peu près voilà et
comme par hasard il a été un peu plus
loin que les autres moi j'étais en
pension on avait un uniforme et je peux
te dire qu'on file droit je te jure et
je me suis à très bien c'était étendre
que le directeur de l'école quand il y
en a un qui bougeait en étude de 5 à 7
pour travailler il passait et un coup de
règles que tu te prenais tu t'y
réfléchissais
et encore de dire qu'il faut frapper
dans une pension dans dans les salles on
avait on avait un uniforme et on filait
droit quoi pardon je suis désolé
forme et donner des coups de règles et
lui
uniforme
vous ne pouvez plus taper les enfants je
vous rappelle que la fessée c'est
interdit pardon Mathieu il parle de
coudre
a changé vous faites ça aujourd'hui vous
êtes devant les tribunaux et Dieu merci
voilà pourquoi on en est là
après vous générez sur quelques idiots
et des des enfants très agressifs
inadmissibles qui doivent être jugés
j'ai vu des tas de vidéos tu as un baume
qui dit au prof qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire ouais qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
et ça c'est une admissible mais vous
pouvez pas généraliser une époque ça
c'est les vieux coups comme vous c'était
mieux avant la vérité toi tu n'as pas
les solutions
[Applaudissements]
on adore
je te dis la vérité
est un homme pondéré d'équilibre vous
militez vous militez pour les coups de
règles sur les enfants voilà ce qu'il a
dit il a donné un exemple en 1920
je dis pas que lui c'est la France de la
victoire j'espère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'effectivement le l'esprit pose
68 heures à gangrène et l'école il est
interdit d'interdire on peut pas mettre
des mauvaises notes aux élèves parce que
aussi non ça allait traumatise ils ont
plus le droit de redoubler on se lève
plus quand il y a le prof qui rentre
donc petit à petit on s'est excusé de
l'autorités
les sévices physiques sont moi une
abomination
physique abomination
bien sûr bien sûr donc c'est formidable
sur les doigts je me suis appris même
une voiture sur les doigts
aussi c'est Gilles Verdez au féminin
c'est la France